so as we are currently crowdfunding Snow
White and the Widow Queen and if you
haven't backed that yet please go ahead
and do that I'm going to put out an
interpretation of Snow White that I made
a few months ago and it's interesting to
look at it because my thoughts on Snow
White has actually moved even further
now as I continue to think about it
continue to have Insight on it we'll get
a few hints of why I make some of the
decisions that I ended up making in Snow
White and the Widow Queen uh but it'll
also be in this continuation of the
celebration of fairy tales that we're
doing now so these are Patron only
videos that I put out over the years so
please enjoy
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you what I'm working on
with the the thing that's fascinating me
right now that the you know a project
that I'm working on I have many many
projects that I often forget to mention
or that I mentioned just in passing but
that take up a lot of my time and uh
hopefully this will also I'll also use
this as an opportunity to give you a few
symbolic hints about what it is we're
talking about and so the project is Snow
White as I've mentioned in some of the Q
and A's I think I've mentioned it is
that I wrote a version of Snow White
it's about five thousand words so it is
a children's fairy tale and it will be
something that I hope people can read in
one sitting with their children
and I am having it Illustrated
by an artist and we're working really
hard to create something which is going
to be absolutely beautiful that is one
of the purposes of this so designing a
whole world designing a whole aesthetic
and working on Snow White and so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to kind of
show you what we're working on what it
looks like and then I will give you a
few Keys about some of the secrets that
are in the Snow White story and the man
in which I'm trying to bring those out
in the the way I'm telling the story
and so here we go
um and so the artists that I've hired to
work with me on this is Heather
paulington
who is someone that I mentioned before
Heather is someone who works on movies
and TV she has worked on many very
famous movies here is her work for
maleficion she's an expert on Surface
design object design but also sets she's
in general she's just being an expert at
color and visual and she's the one who
is also also worked on on the new
branding with it so here's some of her
work on Maleficient you can look her up
online
she's worked on the recent eternals
movie
designing some of the Babylonian slash
Kirby alien objects
so many project Mary Poppins Into the
Woods
Skyfall I mean it's never ending just
amazing work that she's doing
and so the way that we're working on
this is I wrote the I wrote the uh the
story
and uh the way that I wrote this story
is I'm really trying to do what I've
talked about and if you've watched my
Spider-Man uh
video I've talked about what I call
apocalyptic storytelling or
something which is the idea of taking
postmodern the post-modern approach to
storytelling and joining it in a way
that elevates it so the way that we can
ex describe postmodern storytelling is
something like collage storytelling
where we take different references I
mean it's something that you find in in
all works to a certain extent but in the
postmodern world it seems to be taken to
another level where for example you see
um series like exactly like into the
woods for example this like the movie
Into the Woods or once upon a time where
they take all these fairy tales and they
smash them together and they do it in a
way that is kind of dark and is there to
expose the the dark underside of these
fairy tales often there to expose how
they're related to sexuality
um twisting them somehow
so what I want to do is I want to do
something similar which which sounds
weird I guess but it is the idea of
using the kind of cynical Insight that
we get from fairy tales or a good
example would be understanding that
fairy tales do actually treat the
question of sexuality to a certain
extent
um but then showing how the way they
treat it and the way we can see it
can give you an insight about reality
rather than rather than just some dark
inside but maybe an Insight that can
move some towards something more and so
in the story of Snow White that is what
I am and doing as well and the idea is
also to maybe use a kind of conscious
conscious storytelling an awareness of
the fairy tale that is more than just
the naive folk awareness a more subtle
and maybe more sophisticated vision of
the fairy tale but then use that to
reveal what is in the fairy tale rather
than reveal what's in the fairy tale and
how it's related to a more Universal
storyline
and so in the Snow White uh story that
let me give you a little hint about
what's there in the Snow White story
that
that we can help reveal
and so
in the Snow White story in the original
the queen sees that Snow White is
becoming beautiful and of course she
becomes jealous and angry and that is
why she wants to have snow white killed
but what's interesting is that the Queen
the the relationship she has to beauty
is something like she has knowledge of
beauty
and so she sees herself in the mirror
and the mirror tells her that she is the
most beautiful one of all now we could
imagine that that's a magic mirror but
it's not just a magic mirror it's just a
mirror really it's just you could say
it's just a mirror because the mirror
reveals to her a kind of self-awareness
that makes her know that she is the most
beautiful one of all now in the story it
says that Snow White is actually the
most beautiful of all and Snow White is
knows it in she lives it in innocent
she's innocent about her beauty let's
say and that is what makes her the most
beautiful one of all to a certain extent
that is actually what's making her more
beautiful whereas the self-consciousness
of the queen is twisting her we could
say she's also getting older that is
also part of it but that also has to do
with the relationship between fading
this idea of death and the relationship
with beauty so what's fascinating is
that if you understand Snow White that
way
then you realize that the whole story
has to do with that and is actually very
close to the story or the question of
the Fall
and so
when the queen goes out to let's say try
to kill Snow White
in the original story for those who know
it it's not just the Apple she goes
there three times and the first time she
usually brings with her a corset
sometimes it's a ribbon or a corset and
and then she she tells the white that
she should put this on you know to make
her more beautiful you know this this
supplement will make Snow White more
beautiful
and in my version what I've done is I've
made it a belt and I've also made it a
green belt and so for those who know
what that refers to this is the type of
thing I'm talking about where it is
going into fairy tales bringing in to
the fairy tales uh let's say references
to Other Stories which can help you
understand
uh what it is that's going on what it is
we're dealing with here
and so she brings a ribbon or a corset
and then chokes her and she falls then
the second time she usually brings a
comb and in my version what I've done is
that I'm using a hairpin because people
don't really understand the idea of a
comb that's not there just to calm your
hair but it's actually an ornament or uh
you know an ornament to kind of hold
your hair together and then also show
off so it's going to be something like a
like a hairpin that she's going to put
in and that's going to be beautiful now
you can understand the problem which is
that why is Snow White
accepting these gifts
because
why is Snow White accepting these gifts
to make her more beautiful isn't she
already the most beautiful girl in the
world isn't that the whole story is that
what the story is about that Snow White
is the most beautiful one in the world
and so what's interesting is that you
can really see that there's a
relationship between the story of the
fall and this this story which is that
the queen is trying to give her a
supplement to add to her beauty
you know to make her you'd say to make
her conscious of the question of Duty
and the problem of beauty and therefore
make her want to increase her beauty uh
but that's the funny thing about it is
that she's already the most beautiful
one of all so there's a really deep
trick going on a trick that has to do
with the idea of it's like something
like trying to get Eve to wear the
garments of skin something like that
trying to get someone to engage in the
process of supplementarity in a way that
makes you forget or maybe know and
forget in a weird strange way you know
that you are the most beautiful in the
world know in the sense of a kind of
explicit knowledge but forget in the
sense that you feel like you have to
work towards making yourself beautiful
right and so so it's a really super it's
a very very profound story when you kind
of understand it that way
and so what I've done in my version of
Snow White is when the queen comes and
brings the Apple to Snow White she's
going to be suggesting that this apple
will give her knowledge of beauty
and so she says you know don't you want
to know that if you take eat this apple
you will know that you're the most
beautiful
girl in the world but the the joke is
that she's already the most beautiful
girl in the world and it's funny because
when you see it that way you realize
that that's also what's kind of going on
in the story of Adam and Eve because it
says that Adam and Eve were created in
the image of God
and then the serpent comes and says I'm
going to make you like God and so
there's an interesting little story
which is that somehow
they were what they're trying to get
from the Apple for themselves is
something which at least implicitly they
already have and so at some point you
know the idea in the story was that at
some point they were going to get it
explicitly but it would have to be kind
of uh given to them from above but here
you get the sense of the seduction of
knowing that you're beautiful but how
this is also related to an entering into
supplementarity which is the you know
which is the self-consciousness which
forces you to want to add to yourself
and to protect yourself and that
self-consciousness is reflected already
in the image of the queen and the mirror
so it's like once you kind of see the
story of Snow White that way it becomes
this very beautiful and Powerful uh
story that has to do with the fall and
of redemption
now of course there's a lot of other
stuff going on in this which has to do
with the transition between a childhood
and adulthood and this is of course one
of the big secrets of what the story of
Snow White is about and it also helps
you understand
you know you can understand that Snow
White you know
enters into the teenage world she
becomes a teenager and so because of
that she has to deal with the problems
of being a teenager she has to deal with
the problems of becoming a woman
without
the secret of the woman like without
without understanding what the reason is
like without understanding what the
reason of being a woman is and it has to
do with the fusion of blood as you can
imagine which is which is why I think
there's that in the story of Snow White
that there is this this image of the
effusion of blood in the story of Snow
White
um and so Snow White go has to go into
the forest go into she's lost and she
also has to go into this world where
she's dealing with all these little men
all these idiosyncratic men you could
say all these men that aren't
fit for her to be a mate
and also it's the end of the the Disney
version they do a really great job at it
which is that each of the dwarves
represents an idiosyncrasy it's like
here's Sneezy or whatever here's Doc and
here's here's grumpy and it's like all
these and they're just characteristics
idiosyncratic characteristics of of
manhood but they don't they don't come
together in the image of the the prince
which contains it all together in a way
that makes him the proper mate for for
Snow White
so you can understand that you know that
she's in this cycle and she's also
learning to clean and to cook you know
doing the traditional roles that a woman
would do but also facing all this
idiosyncratic masculinity but it's like
so what's what is the point like what is
this for you know what what are we
aiming what is the purpose of this
transformation that I'm going through
which can only be uh found in the the
union the true Union with the met with
the man which is that that is what the
menstrual cycle is for right it's like
you could that's super interesting
because even the most like you know uh
free sex uh
um you know SEC you know lifestyle
whatever that we're dealing with now
it would be very difficult to avoid the
problem which is that that's what the
cycle is for it is for fertility and
without fertility is part of the the
discussion then it's just a point in the
cycle and even you can understand that
in some ways you could say that even
kind of this kind of sexuality without
fertility in any way is also kind of
this point in the cycle and so so why it
is in this world where she's learning to
become a woman she's dealing with all
this idiosyncratic and unattractive and
and small aspects of what masculinity is
um and in a way you could say that it is
in some ways a kind of dying and the the
cycle is of course also a kind of dying
it's a relationship to death this is
something which has been seen
in every single culture pretty much you
know that there's a relationship between
between the menstrual cycle and the moon
moving into its dark phase or this
moving into death and then returning
into life so moving out of fertility and
inter-fertility uh into out into the
residue and into let's say a place of of
true fertility
um but so this is also a form of dying
which is why it makes total sense that
Snow White would be sleeping and so when
the prince awakens her from sleeping
that's what he's awaking her from which
is this pointless this world of
appointless stuff and death and this
transition which is like a baptism you
could say which is this moving down to
death to enter into a new stage of life
you know that is what the print is
Awakening her to and so we can really
see just how profound the story of Snow
White is if we kind of and so the idea
is to write a story to write a version
of Snow White which without explaining
it the way I'm explaining it to you now
actually brings it out exemplifies it in
the story by referencing certain things
by you know um
by referencing certain actually certain
biblical passages and stuff and so
you'll see when you read it but this is
the idea that I want to do for snow
white but also for other
um fairy tales as well so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you some of
the stuff that we're doing in terms of
how it is that we're working on this and
so what we've done and this is this is
of course Heather's work especially is
we're creating a what's called a mural
board so a mural board is a kind of a
board where you can
put down a bunch of ideas and images and
so what we're trying to do is to create
a what we could call a kind of Byzantine
Byzantine fairy tale World which will
would end a certain ornamental World in
which the Snow White story will happen
for some reason some of these titles are
not reading you can kind of see them
appear and disappear I don't know why so
we've got the different references like
we're looking at references for covers
we're looking at the different moods at
Byzantine ornaments of course
um
in terms of the clothing in terms of the
architecture and then looking at certain
illustrators like Billy bin uh Henrik
Lefler
all of these who have worked on a kind
of modern Byzantine style or kind of
modern here is more of a Persian Style
with uh Eric lecane and some Celtic
images as well how to integrate the
world of illustration with a more kind
of Byzantine and medieval aesthetic a
way to to use pattern in clothing which
we really really love
um and how to use also ornamentation in
modern illustration kind of flatness and
3D together so these are kind of some of
these images that we're working with
um all right let's see what else we've
got here
and some of the better versions of Snow
White that have kind of that feel of of
a flatter a more
use of different architectural motifs
inside the Snow White story so you can
give you an idea of the way that we're
looking at these things and we are kind
of using these as inspiration all right
so here's an adherence of two two ones
that are coming closer so you can see
the prints kind of coming up to see Snow
White
and then we're going to use use the two
pages of the book as a storytelling
mechanism so you kind of see two sides
The Prince and Snow White and then the
queen looking in the mirror
um you know and you can have the the
Knight with the waxing moon to show that
Snow White is changing and she's moving
towards her the fullness of herself you
could say and then also the crow so the
crow appears several places in the story
here you can imagine what this is so the
hunter Snow White getting lost in the
forest and then finding the dwarves
house and so this will be like a layout
should be like a layout of two pages
together
so I think it kind of gives you an idea
of how we're working and so hopefully
the idea is that this book will be
something that a parent can read to a
child but that the parent will also get
surprising Insight from the story so
kind of like you see in these cartoons
that they make these like Shrek or like
these cartoons that are made now where
there's like secret adult references in
the story but usually those adult
references are kind of dirty or some
kind of some kind of salty humor or
whatever but here we'll have adult
references which will actually Elevate
the reader into a higher understanding
of what their child is understanding you
know at a at a basic level and so yeah
so that's the idea I hope that you guys
uh appreciate it if you enjoy me taking
you on to these kind of working into
this projects this is something that I
could do because I'm working on a whole
bunch of projects at the same time so
this is a little vision of what's going
on in the future uh you know I really
appreciate you guys supporting me you
know these these projects like the Snow
White Project and even God's dog uh for
me at least at the outset is not
something that I'm making money out of
and so the fact that I've got you guys
to supporting the video work is also
giving me time to work on these kind of
projects and hopefully build this into
something we hope to build it into
something like uh like a media company
that would join the people that I really
love and respect that I'm seeing are
amazing work workers like I'm I'm
already hiring Nicholas cotar part-time
I'm working with Neil degrade on several
projects that hopefully we can talk to
you about in these videos
um and a bunch of other people too like
I said Heather and several others and so
as we kind of keep going hopefully I can
introduce you to some of these projects
and some of the the stuff that I'm that
I'm furiously working on
and uh yeah time is short so we need to
have better stories right I said so so
let's do it so everybody thanks for your
time and uh we'll talk to you very soon
I'm Jonathan Pedro
and I'm inviting you to participate with
us in our retelling and our celebration
of one of the most iconic fairy tales of
all Snow White a beautifully Illustrated
storybook Snow White and the Widow Queen
places our iconic character at the
beginning of eight upcoming fairy tales
which will speak to each other and
harmonize in surprising ways
Snow White and the Widow Queen rekindles
an adventure which will make you
remember ReDiscover but also Marvel and
wonder at our Rich Heritage of stories a
Heritage that still has secrets to
reveal even after centuries of being
passed down to us in the past few
decades we have watched many of our
stories our fairy tales our myths become
completely exhausted by efforts to
deconstruct them to reinvent them and
sometimes to even invert their original
meaning it has come to a point where
we've almost forgotten why we cared
about these stories in the first place
I firmly believe that for this reason it
is now time to retell and redisrupt our
original fairy tales in a spirit of
celebration of admiration and unashamed
joy
I've spent the past two decades
meditating on the strange narrative
elements of Snow White and other fairy
tales after much thinking and now
bringing this story to our common Hearth
we find in the fire of time ready to
present Hidden Treasures most of us have
never noticed to accomplish this I have
paired up with Heather paulinton a
world-class artist and designer who has
worked on some of the most beloved film
franchises of our time
her work mirrors my writing and
collaboration that has produced a
powerful synthesis of medieval style
with the best of 19th and 20th Century
illustration I love the kickstarter
model because we can make the book more
and more beautiful with every stretch
book we can offer art prints a limited
edition drawing by Heather and even a
snow white illustration of my own
we're planning a super exclusive
leather-bound Edition which pulls out
all the stops a storybook mantelpiece
for sure
the prophets of this crowdfunder will be
used to start a new Publishing Company
symbolic World Press who's christening
publication will be this very fairy tale
series
each book illustrated by world-class
artists Jack and the Beanstalk
Cinderella the Valiant little Taylor and
several more are next in line for
publication all existing in the same
world and all fitting together like a
puzzle moving towards the final
surprising resolution
after all that there's no limit to what
we can do
it's time to reset the clock to retell
our stories to join us in this
celebration and create Adventure
[Music]